it seems like this is a person who has a
issue with parking absolutely that part
is just blew my mind
it's a murder detective say was over a
partially blocked driveway tonight our 8
news now investigators learning this
wasn't the first time an accused killer
allegedly fired shots over a parking
spot eight news now investigator David
charns with the case that wasn't solved
until after police say a man shot and
killed his neighbor
this is the last place I was with him so
it's hard for me to just want to get up
and leave from here Stacy Owen sits in
her living room where her boyfriend her
best friend died from a gunshot
that day was um
a lot that day October 18th of last year
34 year old Christopher Allen dice as
his friends call him was out on the
street working on this car photos show
the car parked here on this Southeast
Valley Street a detective telling Owens
this about what happened next she said
that there was some type of
Confrontation over parking police say
41-year-old Robert Salone came home
finding Alan's car blocking part of his
driveway Allen couldn't move his car
because he was in the middle of changing
a tire seconds later
emergency
call zero zero all right
say Salone shot twice into Allen's car
once into his chest remnants of that day
seared not only in Owen's memory but
into the wall next to her front door
what's it like
walking past that bullet hole every day
or a conster reminder police would soon
learn that shot and the two others
lodged in Allen's car were not the only
ones Salone allegedly fired over a
parking spot in August 2021 police say a
person who took up two parking spots at
this Henderson apartment complex also
became salone's victim records the 8
news now investigators obtained showed
that person told officers he was
visiting friends when he quote double
parked taking up two parking spaces here
in this covered spot he came back to his
car finding another one parked within
inches of the door he also found an
angry driver who police suspect is
Salone arguing with him it wasn't until
the bullets in these crime scene photos
matched the ones in these that police
connected Salon to both parking related
crimes Scott Martin is a retired Captain
with the Department of Public Safety the
first thing that kind of caught my
attention was they couldn't identify
this person documents say Henderson
Police classified the shooting as
gang-related saying the victim was not
forthcoming and later recommending the
case be closed detectives believe Saloon
was living at that complex for at least
a month after the shooting until he and
his girlfriend abruptly moved out in
September even though she had signed a
lease through the end of the following
March it could be a hard thing to solve
I think Martin agrees finding so long
would prove difficult with no evidence
other than a description and the
cartridge Cases left behind while Salone
is listed in Metro records as a 41 year
old black male records show
investigators in Henderson listed their
suspect as a white man between 30 and
35. there may have been something in
that investigation that didn't look
right as far as the victim's story
ultimately testing would show stamps
from salone's Ghost guns matched in both
parking spot shootings it's absolutely a
thing it's it's absolutely insane it's
just something you don't this is not
something you hear of every single day
Owen's wishes Henderson Police had
solved their parking spot shooting
before Metro Police say the same man
killed her partner they got him a month
after Allen's murder Salone returned
home where police welcomed him with
handcuffs Owens taking this video just
steps away from that constant reminder
in her wall of what happened here it
wasn't even just the love of my life
that was my best friend and
now I will never see him again
we reached out to the Henderson shooting
victim and Witnesses listed in this
police report and did not receive a
response Robert Salone also declined to
speak with us his trial for charges of
murder and ones for the prior parking
spot shooting scheduled for September
I'm David charms 8 news now David also
reached out to Henderson Police for
comment we have not yet received their
response